[Applause]
well done
everybody happy Wednesday everybody
a so as you know Trump won big in Iowa
which means it's time for Democrats to
freak out of course it's always time for
Dems to freak out unless it bring up the
border the economy crime or Biden
getting lost in his
yard then there's nothing to see here
folks but Trump really seems to bring
out their inner Kathy Griffin
hell even Joy Reed bought a Donald Trump
wig oh it's true thought it was a socer
but the closer he gets to the White
House the closer they get to committing
Harry Carey with a pair of dull knitting
needles they see Trump in their brain
sees up like Obama's appetite when he
watches a dog
show he eats dogs so what's really going
on what are they planning next well it's
to push the idea that Trump will stage a
total Arian takeover and NBC helped
plant this seed with this headline quote
fears grow that Trump will use the
military in dictatorial ways if he
returns to the White House end quote
sounds pretty scary right but that's the
setup here's more Donald Trump is
sparking fears among those who
understand the inner workings of the
Pentagon that he would convert the
nonpartisan US military into the
muscular arm of his political agenda as
he makes comments about dictatorships
and devalues the checks and balances
that underpin the nation's two Century
old
democracy by the way sparking fears is
code for let's scare you about things
that haven't happened and only exist in
our demented minds and who are these
mysterious experts well like Raymond
ororo trying to make a rap
album no one wants to be on the record
damn
NBC refers to them as quote a loose-knit
network of public interest groups and
lawmakers who are quietly devising plans
to try to foil any efforts to expand
Presidential Power now that sounds a lot
more like a well- financed network of
Lefty know-it-alls who never recovered
from Hillary getting spanked in
2016 and my apologies for that
imagery but you can see where this is
going it's another cabal another soft
coup their plan involves quote preparing
to take legal action and send letters to
Trump appointees spelling out
consequences they'd face if they
undermined constitutional Norms this is
crazy it kind of sounds like that letter
of 5050 Intel experts that spontaneously
sprung up when Hunter's laptop dropped
amazing how they had that ready right no
collusion between the media government
and Democrats there see the NBC article
is designed to make you think past the
sale to assume Trump will indeed ask the
military to do something very bad when
he's elected and so this story is to
prep you for their aggression and not
Trump's because the very same people
putting this plan together the same who
will encourage militant resistance to
Trump and they want to make sure he
can't respond if and when things turn
violent the problem none of this is real
if Trump's plan is to use the military
for his own gain why didn't he do it the
first time you know he had four years to
do that and he didn't even invade Canada
which is a
gimme so
easy so if Trump really wanted to become
a dictator then why isn't he one he had
the chance yet the Dems keep sparking
fears like he's some new unknown threat
out of nowhere the man was in Home Alone
too for Pete's
sake he didn't even send troops to break
up Prince Harry and Megan marle and we
know he should have
and if they're so worried about a
president violating constitutional Norms
why are they cheering while Joe Biden
directs the use of lawfare against his
probable opponent in
2024 why because Libs always accuse
Republicans of the crap they do
themselves weaponizing the IRS done
using the FBI to set up citizens from
parents at school board meetings to
anybody within five miles of the capital
on January 6 done and done so you think
Trump will lead us into World War III
then how do you ignore Biden flirting
with it we to weak to them Trump who
loved the military yet rarely used it is
the potential dictator while Biden can't
wait to bog our forces down in Ukraine
the Middle East China hell the guy just
ordered military strikes without
Congressional approval all while his
defense secretary can only be reached
using his doctor's index
finger I don't know why aren't they
saying a thing about Biden interfering
in the investigation of Hunter the
presidential son who puts the penis in
defying
subpoenas it works it's in there
somebody should tell Joe his first job
is to protect the American people not
just his brother and idiot son see it's
Biden who's ignoring the rule of law at
the border it's Biden who's
unconstitutionally forgiving student
loans paying off young voters with our
money it's Biden who sees America as his
kingdom but okay let's say Trump
declares himself president for life and
the military goes along what would that
even look like Trump first day as
dictator might be this one open Windows
replace Biden old man smell with my own
old man's
smell two nuke enemies in tyon and
Harvard three lunch Trump Stakes extra
ketchup for charge Hillary Clinton with
murder not so bad oh I'm kidding you are
terrible people so what you're seeing
from the left is pure projection and
it's giving people a reason to vote for
Trump because once again he's pissing
off the right people all these hacks
suddenly care about the president
violating the Constitution but never
with a democrat in the Oval Office and
Biden has the 25th Amendment written all
over him along with do not resuscitate
which was added by kamla
Harris the only time the Press ever
challenges the president is when he's a
republican so if you vote for Biden
you're giving them four more years off
and come on I just don't think Trump
wants to be dictator who waits till he's
80 to become Hitler not even
Hitler let's
welcome guest he calls himself a
comedian which proves he has a sense of
humor actor writer and comedian Jamie
low little known fact KT stands for
killer tonsils former deputy National
Security adviser KT
mcar if you mess with her she'll stab
you with her elbows New York Times
bestselling author and foxus contributor
cat and he's quick with a scowl but wise
as an owl New York Times bestselling
author comedian in former NWA world
champion Jamie when I read that article
I got the sense that they were setting
the table up for a preemptive strike
it's like when someone gets ready to put
it in your world somebody is preparing
to divorce somebody else they'll create
like a pro
so it looks Justified you know are they
doing that with Trump kind of setting
the premise to take them out I think
you're right it's things that will
probably never it's like like it's like
I I like to watch this movie every night
before I go to bed I watch the same
movie I close my eyes and I watch
everything you've ever done wrong in
your whole
life and I like that's what they're
doing it's like this worst case and
everything man did you make a good point
he was already president and he didn't
do any of these things that's the whole
point I heard when Biden saw this he was
like oh man I could have asked him to do
that stuff
um did you hear there was a lot I I
trust Trump way more than I ever trust
Biden being being president I get
worried about did you hear when Biden
first became president he almost
pardoned some people by mistake they
they were like uh Andrew Snowden and he
was like
pardon I'm GNA be honest I can't stop
thinking about Hillary getting spanked
yeah um I just feel like if she had been
into that maybe Bill wouldn't straight
outside the
[Laughter]
marriage yeah KT um do you think I'm
overstating this or understating this
that they're preparing for something
you're you're understating it a thank
you so much okay so here and and let me
just it's actually a really serious
constitutional thing so in 2016 working
with the Hillary campaign the FBI and
the justice department decided they were
going to make sure Hillary won well that
didn't work right the American people
voted voted for President Trump so then
they weaponized the FBI the Mueller
investigation all these various
Congressional investigations to try to
sabotage Trump's presidency so nobody
ever was called nobody was ever held
responsible right the Russia hoax went
on and on and on nobody was ever held
accountable fast forward 2020 the CIA
got on the ACT and there was a sitting
CIA official who coordinated with those
51 Former Intelligence Officers to say
the hunter Biden laptop was Russian
disinformation they knew it was not
Russian disinformation they lied they
kept their security clearances all those
people were any of them ever held to
account no so they've gotten away with
it twice they're going to try to get
away with it the third time I and a
number of people who' worked for
president Trump have been trying to
figure out where is it going to come
next time and they've just tipped their
hat where is it going to come from the
military there you go very chilling
stuff cat you're a constitutional lawyer
I believe Jonathan Turley was one of
your
students yeah he always calls me for my
opinion on I know I know you know um
doesn't this S I guess it's not
technically treason yet but if they're
pressuring the military to subvert the
commander-in-chief and he wins how is
that not treason
cat you're
weird I just I read this whole thing and
they makes a lot of assumptions and I I
feel like I would like to see some
polling on some of these things mhm uh
for example January 6th they seem to be
concerned about like a new and improved
January 6 cuz January 6th it it didn't
work and I've heard a lot of things said
about January 6 I mean we talk about it
all the time everybody's talking about
one thing I've not heard a single person
Express is fomo MH I've not heard a
single person be like man I wish I would
have been there yeah but I'll I'll
definitely be at the next
one po Republicans be like do you you
regret not being at January 6th would
you like to be at a future new and
improved January 6th before you start
going and saying that this is all going
to be a possibility and it's going to be
a takeover is this actually a
possibility is this something that's in
people's hearts and Minds because the
article was like according to people
familiar with which is so interesting
because they're actually kind of doing a
version of Trump's version of sourcing
it's not that far off from just doing
the many people are saying yeah yeah
yeah and you know you're right it's like
there's nobody who said let's do Jan 6
again nobody I haven't heard anyone say
I wish I would have gone I know I know I
definitely won't miss it next time and
you know what the funny thing is Trump
is more popular since January 6th than
before January 6th how crazy is that
maybe I'm wrong maybe there's a lot of
people who just think all day about how
much they want to be at the next one do
the polling let me see more people want
to go to the Lilith
there what am I ah one woman got that
reference we know which side she's on
all right Tyrus uh is this Trump
derangement or an actual plot no this is
a plot uh but the Democratic party or
the the the artist formerly known as a
Democratic party the Socialist Party
they usually they don't tip their hats
they spill it out on the table for us
like they're like the kids who can only
finish half the Lego and they need
president Trump to do the rest for them
yeah so the new move is one they're not
going to debate yeah okay and they're
they're argument doesn't work and you
can always look back in history and you
and I will send each other movies to
watch right we I watched the polling we
watched the polling right there was a
scene where he advocated right they
didn't like during when he was Emperor
he was horrible and cared about you know
the French people having food on their
tables the real jerk he avocad he leaves
they put him on island he comes back and
they meet him with the military and he
says to the military I miss you guys how
are you I'd like to be your King again
and they said said well all right and
that was
it what the Democrats are trying to do
is what they're not going to let
Napoleon come back and meet them before
he gets there they're going to have
their people in place in the military
saying we are going to stop him before
he gets to office so what they're trying
to do is one make voting irrelevant
because they know better than us but
they're laying out that that storyline
and we said it for jump there will be no
debates because President Biden's not
going to debate with a convicted
criminal mhm
it's beneath the office of the
presidency so there's that kamla won't
debate with whomever he's running with
for those very same reasons anyone who
supports Trump is a crazy yeah that's
the new talk it's the crazies and the
crazies is not
just regular John and Jane tax player
anymore it's anybody who works or
affiliate with him as a part of the the
coup nobody wants Jan 62 because
everyone who even thought about on Jan
5th is under the jail yeah like they all
were arrested but if you ask the other
side about looting in Minnesota soon
that line is long so we just need they
they always lay it out to play it out
for us they're going to do this and then
when if he does win the erection they'll
just have the military in place to
arrest him for treason because we're
seeing it he didn't do anything with
January 6 wasn't convicted or anything
but yet they have courts taking him off
the ballot based off of what feelings
feelings versus facts and feelings are
just fancy lies people tell themselves
feel
better all right we got to move on KT
unless you have something explosive to
say I'm we're going to go to the break
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else